OUR NEXT GAME, TRANSMISSION
CONTROL.
TRANSMISSION CONTROL.
>> 38 YEARS AGO, THIS
SATURDAY, A POWERFUL RADIO
TELESCOPE KNOWN AS THE BIG
EAR RECEIVED A TRANSMISSION
FROM DEEP SPACE KNOWN TODAY
AS THE WOW SIGNAL BECAUSE OF
THIS NOTE,
WRITTEN THE NIGHT IT WAS
DISCOVERED IN 1977.
THE ALLEGED 72 SECOND ALIEN
MESSAGE/BINGO CARD
WHICH CAME FROM THE STAR
CONSTELLATION SAGGITARIUS
SOUNDS LIKE THIS.
NOW THIS HAS NEVER ACTUALLY
BEEN DECODED.
BUT TO MY EXPERT EAR IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE ALIENS WERE
CONNECTING TO THEIR MODEM.
AT A SPEED OF 14,4, I
BELIEVE.
SO COMEDIANS, IN HONOR OF
THIS MYSTERY, I WANT TO YOU
GIVE AS MANY OTHER MESSAGES
WE MIGHT RECEIVE FROM
SPACE AS YOU CAN, IN 60
SECONDS.
AND BEGIN.
>> SARAH.
>> YOU UP?
>> POINTS.
>> NAT.
>> MAJOR TOM TO GROUND
CONTROL.
>> POINTS.
>> GET ME THE [BLEEP] OUT OF
HERE.
>> BRETT
>> HEY, IT'S OUTER SPACE
CALLING YOU BACK.
>> YES, POINTS.
>> SARAH.
>> IS BILL PULLMAN STILL
PRESIDENT?
>> POINTS.
>> TELL TOM CRUISE WE'LL BE
BACK TO PICK HIM UP ANY
MOMENT.
>> POINTS.
>> BRETT GELMAN.
>> HEY, IT'S OUTER SPACE
AGAIN.
I WAS WATCHING "RICKY FLASH"
AND YOU KNOW, I HAD IT ON
AIRPLANE MODE. I DON'T KNOW
IF YOU TRIED TO CALL ME BACK
AND DIDN'T LEAVE A
MESSAGE BUT I --
>> POINTS.
>> BRETT.
>> HEY, IT'S OUTER SPACE
AGAIN, I JUST REALIZED, I
PROMISED YOU THAT I WOULD GO
SEE "RICKY FLASH" WITH YOU.
I'M REALLY SORRY ABOUT THAT.
I HAVE NO PROBLEMS SEEING IT
AGAIN, NO PROBLEM AT ALL.
>> ARE YOU TALKING THE MOVIE
"RICKY AND THE FLASH."
>> YES.
>> I GOT TO DO IT ALL AGAIN.
I GOT TO --
>> [BLEEP] NO. IT IS "RICKY
FLASH" AND THAT'S IT.
>> SARAH.
>> SAY "SQUAD GOALS" ONE MORE
TIME AND I WILL BLOW YOUR PLANET
UP.
>> POINTS.
>> IT'S ME AGAIN, OUTER
SPACE. I REALIZE I HAVE BEEN
CALLING THE MOVIE "RICKY
FLASH," IT'S "RICKY AND THE
FLASH," PROBABLY, YOU
PROBABLY KNOW THAT. I JUST
WANT TO BE CLEAR.
I WANT TO BE CLEAR ABOUT
THAT.
>> POINTS.
>> OUTER SPACE IS REALLY
ANNOYING.
>> HE'S REALLY, YOU KNOW, HE'S
REALLY DESPERATE.